we've all seen the dramatic briefings uh
overnight it's always hard to unpick
exactly what is going on from the
rhetoric
but i was hoping you might be able to
help us
what is the situation with those trade
talks and
how likely is it that we're going to get
a deal
well the british negotiating team is
returning to brussels today
following the conversation that took
place between the prime minister and the
commission president
yesterday these are it's in a very
difficult position there's no point
denying that
for several months now there have been
sticking points around issues such as
access on uh fisheries and also
so-called level playing field provisions
there was some hope early last week some
progress
was being made and at one point it
looked like there might be a a
breakthrough but obviously then the
european union added a whole load of
additional demands
after that which caused some problems so
you know we're going to continue to work
we'll continue
continue to work on these negotiations
until there's no point in doing so any
further
but there's no point denying either that
what happened late last week was a
setback
it's interesting you mentioned that
about the eu adding these last minute
demands
i can't help wondering if this is all
part of the charade
last minute unreasonable sounding
demands that eventually the eu pulls you
can claim a win
and then actually just end up caving in
on all the other disagreements before
well we will find out in the next day or
two whether it is the sort of um
you know exercises that the eu's engaged
in maybe to have one final try to get a
few other things over the line
whether this is a sort of a
choreographed thing on their part
to to say they've tried and then back
down who knows
but what i do know is that we as a
government have had a very clear
position from the beginning on this
we're negotiating with the eu as a
sovereign equal
there are certain things we've been
clear from the start that
we cannot compromise on and that is our
sovereignty as a nation our ability to
control our own laws and our ability to
control access to our waters those have
been
clear from the beginning and while of
course in these areas we can give
undertakings and have
political agreements we can't do
anything that fundamentally violates our
sovereignty and we've been clear on that
from the start
i'm interested about this idea of not
doing anything that violates the
sovereignty fishing of course is one of
those totemic issues that everyone
can grasp level playing field i think
perhaps is something that you know a lot
of
people's eyes let's be honest glaze over
when they hear about it but it is
really important it's the extent to
which the uk has to follow
eu rules and standards it could have a
huge impact on our economy
whereas in economic terms fishing has
you know around
0.1 of the uk economy i can't help
wondering are we going to get to a stage
where
you can claim a win on fishing but you
cave in on level playing field
and you just hope that it's fine because
no one really understands what it means
well look on the so-called level playing
field uh
provisions you know there is precedent
for agreement in other trade agreements
not least
the eu-canada agreement where
undertakings are given that you
you know won't renege or water down your
for
environmental standards or others
product standards so there are
there are ways in a normal trade
agreement where
some reassurance and undertakings can be
given and
of course we've always been insurances
on level playing field
yes but provided they're within the
realms of a normal trade agreement
between sovereign equals
where it becomes difficult is if the eu
starts to say things like well unless
you clear your agree you know your
regulations with us before
we reserve the right to to pull certain
parts of the agreement and to undermine
what's been agreed
and so it's um it's it's the difference
between
giving an undertaking that's quite
normal in a trade agreement that
um you're not going to sort of diminish
standards on
technical standards on products or
indeed environmental standards
but without fettering your ability as an
independent country
to make your own laws and that's
something that we won't do
what's the situation on phishing because
it has sounded like you're an awfully
long way
apart what exactly is the eu demanding
now
and what are we asking for
well look the big problem with the
common fisheries
policy is it's been profoundly unfair to
uk fishermen
we currently only under eu law are
allowed to
catch half of the fish in our waters the
other half has always been given away
to other eu countries and what we've
been clear about is as we
leave the european union we want to
become like norway and control
access to our waters who can come in on
what terms
and also to use that access to
rebalance the sharing arrangement
towards something that's more modern and
more scientific
and crucially fairer to our own
fishermen and that's all we've been
asking for
well i suppose not surprisingly um you
know the european union would like to
have
the same privileges of access that they
have now
but that's simply not going to be
possible when we become an independent
coastal state so
you know what can be done here is um
it's possible and there's precedent in
normal fisheries agreements for there to
be a multi-annual agreement of perhaps
up to three years
where there's an understanding around
access and sharing that happens for
instance already
with mackerel in the north sea but um
what you can't do is give some sort of
treaty guarantee
of access that again you know violates
the the basic principle that
we should be able to control who have
access to our waters and under what
terms
so just to get into the specifics uh
because it's quite you know just trying
to pick exactly where we are in the
talks is it right to say the eu is
saying that they will return
18 of what they have at the minute and
we're asking for 80
is that still how far apart we are or
hasn't moved
well look i see lots of figures um
banded about
and i'm not going to get into the
specifics of it but but broadly
broadly speaking yes the the eu have
suggested a very
modest increase um that they would uh
tolerate the uk having
of the fish in its own waters but given
that we only have half
of the fish in our own waters now that
simply wouldn't be possible
and there's also the more important
principle that you would not be able to
give any guarantees for the long term
otherwise
you're effectively giving a guaranteed
access in perpetuity to our waters
uh under you know which is just not
right under international law it would
be the only country in the entire world
that could agree that so such a
suggestion really is quite ludicrous and
just not consistent
with international law so are you saying
then that the report that we are only
happy to
have this transition for three years is
correct is that right
well look i'm not going to get into the
details of the negotiations but what i
would say
is that it is well there are details but
um
but i what i would say is as i said
earlier
in a normal fisheries uh management
agreement
it's not unusual to have a multi-annual
agreement
for three years where there's an
understanding that there'll be a certain
degree
of mutual access in one another's waters
and an understanding about a fair
sharing arrangement within
that multi-annual period of say three
years that's
got precedent that's quite normal in
fisheries
agreements were open to having a
discussion along those
sorts of lines but certainly what we
cannot do
is give an agreement where there's
effectively
long-term guaranteed access particularly
when there's no
agreement on on sharing arrangements
fisheries is a dynamic marine
environment you have to be able to
change things
quite regularly as the science changes
and the health of stock changes
stocks migrate they move that's why
these things have to be regularly
reviewed
you really can't set things uh in stone
for the long term indeed
that's why the common fisheries policy
has been such a dismal failure
and the irish foreign minister simon
covany has said this morning that it's
not
credible for the uk to say it can manage
a no deal scenario is he right
well i know we've always been clear that
if we cannot get an agreement we will
leave as the prime minister says on
australia terms without a further
negotiated outcome we've actually been
uh done
doing huge amounts of work on this for a
long period of time
we had done a lot of preparation to
leave without an agreement last october
and we've been preparing ever since for
the prospect
of potentially having to leave without
an agreement at the end of this year
we'll be ready to do so uh if that is uh
what transpires
if you don't agree a deal by tomorrow
are you going to reinstate the parts of
the internal markets bill that break
international law and are you preparing
to introduce the finance bill that does
the same
yes we will these clauses are very
important
you know in the event particularly an
event that we leave obviously without an
agreement
it's very important that where the joint
committee process between the eu
and uk fails to come up with clarity
about how
the northern ireland protocol should be
interpreted
it's absolutely crucial that the uk
government has the powers to provide the
legal clarity and the legal certainty
that business will require at that point
and if the deal is done those clauses
will be dropped
well what we're saying is these powers
we brought them in
uh particularly when we were hoping
actually for that to be in agreement
they may be needed under any scenario in
a way
but if the joint committee process is
unable to come up with
the clarity that's needed about how the
withdrawal agreement should be
interpreted
given that it affects northern ireland
which is you know part of the uk
the uk government will have to legislate
to provide
uh the legal clarity and legal certainty
about how that agreement should be
interpreted only the uk government can
do that
okay well we'll have to see how those uh
talks go in the next 24 hours so it
feels like a really critical
period in those negotiations i'm keen to
talk to you about another thing that i
know
lots of our viewers are really concerned
about and that's the vaccine
rollout the pfizer beyond tech vaccine
is
beginning to come to the uk the uk's
ordered 40 million doses that's enough
to vaccinate
20 million people let's talk about some
numbers when can we expect to get the
doses how are you going to get and when
we're going to get them
well my understanding is that it's
actually going to begin its rollout this
week
i think uh the first consignments of the
vaccine are on their way from
belgium indeed i talked to my own local
nhs
authority in cornwall at the end of last
week they're already
uh planning to have it arrive and to
start deploying it
this week so this week um eight hundred
thousand dollars is that right
i don't have the precise number on doses
but we're certainly yes commencing in
earnest this week huge amounts of
planning has gone on over the
last couple of months into how we would
deploy a vaccine that's been thought
about for some time
the nhs obviously have got quite a lot
of experience in rolling out
vaccines this particular vaccine does
have those challenges and that it needs
to be
stored at minus 70 degrees and and once
it's
thawed down there are limits on the
number of moves
that you can make with it without
affecting its viability
so there are some challenges with it but
a lot of work and planning has been
going into this for some months
i understand of course that you're not
going to be across every single bit of
detail and everything people will cut
you
a lot of slack for that but it feels to
me to be
very very important possibly the number
one issue right now
on how many doses of the vaccine are
going to be in the uk
next week and you don't know
look i know that we have 40 million
doses of the
uh the fisa vaccine we're not gonna get
40 million next week
i know that people need uh two doses of
that
uh that vaccine so there's enough of the
fisa vaccine
to inoculate 20 million people we've
also got access as well to
a hundred million doses of the astra
zenica vaccine which is
sorry to interrupt you but this is the
whole point isn't it like we know we've
got access to all these but the big
question marks about how quickly
we're going to get them in the country
and there's it seems to be a huge
disparity between having
you know 40 million doses of advisor
vaccine but how many are we going to
have next week
well look um i'm sure that if uh if you
were to talk to a health minister
who were nadim to highway who's
obviously working on this
at the moment he would be able to give
you that precise figure i'm not in
charge of the dispatch of the vaccine
from belgium to the uk i don't know
the precise number that might be
traveling here at this moment but i do
know that we've got access to 40 million
doses
i do know that it's going to be deployed
in earnest from this week
okay might be helpful to talk to nadim
zahari to find out before
um there has been some concern that
brexit could disrupt the delivery
of the vaccine is it correct that you're
looking at using military aircraft to
get it into the country
well we it won't disrupt the the vaccine
we've
got huge amounts of work has gone on to
maintain the flow of goods at the border
in the event of there being a no deal
brexit and we've also got
contingency plans in place including a
government procured
ferry that's on standby and of course
the option should it be needed to use
airfreight too
we've got many contingency plans in
place there won't be any effect on the
deployment of this vaccine
from a no deal brexit okay um well yeah
hugely important we'll have to see how
that rollout goes
uh next week as you say big logistical
challenge too
while i've got you there's just one
question that i wanted to get your
views on now this week we saw some
football fans
returning to stadiums and at a millwall
game
when the players took the knee to
support black lives matter
there was an awful lot of booing by
supporters what was your reaction to
that
well look i didn't see that event i know
that uh
look obviously the the issue of race and
racial discrimination is something that
we all take very very seriously my
personal view is that uh black lives
matter capital
b l and m is actually a political
movement that is uh that is different
uh to what uh most of us believe in
which is standing up for racial equality
but look each individual can take their
own choices about
how they reflect this and i know a lot a
number of people feel quite strongly and
have taken that approach
i understand what you're saying about
how your personal view is a political
thing but i just want to play you
because you say you haven't heard it
what happened at millwall because
i mean it is quite shockingly let's just
hear it
[Applause]
you can hear the strength of those boos
given the fact there's not that many
people in the stadium
what's your reaction just listening to
that
yes i'm afraid i'm listening on a sort
of walkie-talkie in the middle of a
street with a
a bus going behind me so but look um
there there has been problems obviously
with uh with
racism in football in the past it's
right that that's called out
and challenged when we when we see it
it doesn't have any place in society
today
and if people choose to express
their view in a particular way that
should always be respected